welcome to this video playing Alvar
alonso am I am Alva Alonso what is he
playing here and Bishop c8 what is this
what is your problem mister of Alonso
okay I don't know did I do something to
piss him off or what I don't know what a
gay i'm just playing on museum we can
play those temple losses if he likes not
trying to earn rap if you refute that
immediately i'm just doing normal stuff
so like h3g form and g3 h4 I'm sorry
that could be an idea
it's difficult not to play this I think
so guess he had to one thing is the
diagonal opening here give some
immediate mine ideas not it's not not
very safely placed but I'm going for I'm
direct to check here anyway so doesn't
matter non-threatening night age seven
yeah i was thinking queen age five
should be good just would be weird if
not actually with white attacking with
all pieces
yeah so Knight f6 rook f6
that's it's very nice for me but am i
winning this is the only question am i
winning or not 96 maybe she takes Bishop
takes 26 it's not entirely convincing
hmm can I can move the light somewhere
else not sure where exactly and 9060
care of 694 does not does not really do
that much
hmm there should be some kind of should
be something decisive really not seeing
it though
not really seeing it um if he moves the
night okay I have to play a move there
that's maybe his idea with this wacky
opening yeah that I that I'm spending a
long time trying to completely refuted
and not them yeah enter and losing the
track there with at the time okay look
at five I thought 96 is a move okay it's
not doing that now I can do now g5 again
but you will move the move it i guess
95-97 don't see a decisive blow there
but i can take now here right don't see
anything wrong with that so if i just
take age 64 95 isn't that right sure
that should be decisive or not no GTA 5
is got queen f2 okay that's true i can
go h5 though what is your move then 97
96 check is made i simply don't believe
that that holds him we should be for
this should be for Queen f2 checking
edge one that also wins for white unless
there's some kind of miracle defense I
don't know very much download time yeah
okay check this made next move that's
not exactly difficult now
black resins Joe well okay gifted each
one so who's in the opening I really
don't know why anyway so i don't know i
just played normal stuff and then see
what happened probably something quicker
was possible i played it to know and
then somewhat yeah didn't try anything
fancy let's say so this this and no yeah
okay that no 96 does win okay the
immediate 96 this is this check check
I'm back ok now for for this so what
happens after this i know i can take and
go and go night of 7 and windows i win
the whole who bunch of pieces there okay
that was actually stronger chest but i
took took here i thought this is losing
yeah that is losing so look and had to
go back the engine still wants to play
nine to six month yet it who where i saw
it but I couldn't really I couldn't
really work out of him winning here ok
after Queen e7 I go Bishop g5 that's
pretty pretty nice damn and I'm winning
the exchange as he cannot take checkmate
so this was my choice but that also wins
so I didn't do anything stupid and it
really does win if he takes e4 I think
with the bishop this is just one check
and so wins he's playing without to
pieces
time and this was of course now made so
he could have played this after which I
just have winning endgame but well I had
one minute something it could have been
could have led to some dramatic moments
no idea why he went for this weird
opening we have no particular history
I'm up two points but don't really
remember anything specific from the
games okay well thanks for watching